Now that you have all this installed
your instance is ready to be used as
a node in the hoodoo cluster.
You can easily save it and
launch multiple copies by
creating an amazon machine image.
Usually just called image.
When you use this image to launch
an instance it will already have
all the software installed.
>From the dashboard go
to the instances list.
Select the instance, then actions,
image, create image.
Give it a name something like
a dupe node then save it.
Click AMI in the sidebar.
After a few minutes you should
see the image raster here.
If you come back to start up another
cluster you can launch this image and
you'll have nodes with Java
hoodoo already installed.
[BLANK_AUDIO]